alright it might be noticing this is the
exact same as the last be log I did uh
that's because I actually went through
three episodes the past few days I just
didn't have time to film them so next
episode I'm probably be wearing this -
it'll be the exact same shot so I know
you're heartbroken uh and also warned
you I cannot say this guy's name it's
the guy and I know I'm terrible with
names like it's like a running thing for
these but Renee I would do road odo from
D space 9 I I'm mentioning that name
because I really like him as a voice
actor I like it as a regular actor - uh
that voice actors aren't regular actors
that you know that me a live-action
actor and he always does good work but I
don't mention him because I can't say
his fucking name I always just call Otto
from Star Trek so apologies if you're
watching very unlikely but with that
said this episode is the northern air
temple right yes the northern air temple
I like this one a lot what I like about
it is that it tackles an argument that
is still going on today in many respects
and is still a very difficult balance
and what I mean in this one this is the
one where Aang goes to that they find
the northern air temple there's another
air temple P checked here and there's
also more end but airbenders which
sounds phenomenal they go this temple
and it turns out it's just people who
are really good at engineering devices
that make it look like they're flying
like hang gliders and little planes and
so forth balloons so on so forth and
he's disappointed but at the same time
well it's good to see the temple again
but the big problem is that the temple
has been taken over many parts have been
ripped apart to make way for new
technology to make way for them to
create other means of survival and
evolving and technological marvels
but it's destroying a place that's a
very sacred it's very sacred ground
so ankles in it's like going to a place
that it's like going to your old
childhood
a home and seeing all this incredible
artwork that you did or maybe your folks
did or something that you cherished and
there's big pipes coming through them
like through their faces if you drew
faces or whatever I mean just this
incredible artwork and the stuff that to
him is very sacred uh very much altered
taken down ripped apart not for the
means of demeaning the artwork or going
against anything sacred but because the
people going in here they don't know
what it is they just know hey we can use
this room to make our machines and we
can use this room too and or plumbing
and we could you know we can survive
here so that was very interesting and
Aang is looking at this temple just
shaking his head like that this was a
sacred place but he's also dealing with
the idea well but these people need to
survive and they are doing good well for
the most part of what we'll get to a
second um and they are very much trying
to develop things that will be good and
there's people trying to live their
lives and trying to live good lives you
know there's there's a kid who he can't
use his legs but they create a glider
where he can fly through the skies
that's why it's unbelievable um and the
the inventor Rene Ohno from deep space 9
is the guy who makes most of this stuff
and he's a very nice guy and and he's
eccentric and he likes to work with
different inventions they sort of talks
with Sokka about different ways of like
finding a gas leak and I like the
ingenuity of this I like how they they
work off each other um I like sock has
really been given much more of a
character which I like all right yeah
honestly it was always kind of there I'm
not gonna have like it wasn't it was
more than the humor was a touch off but
they've always given him sort of this
nice honorable part to him in between
all the humor but now it really it seems
more and more like he's very well
balanced before the humor was a little
up it seems very well balanced now like
I really genuinely like this character I
never disliked him but I now really like
him just as much as guitar
dang so they get to they get to this
place and they find out that photo from
deep space behind is actually making
weapons for the Fire Nation which is
like wow but it turns out that he sort
of had no choice if they wanted to live
there if they want to live in peace the
Fire Nation Fire Nation would need him
to keep making weapons so egg finds us
out here's the explanation that the son
of auto from Star Trek is crushed and
they tried to figure out a way around
this which I like it would have been it
probably would've been easy just to make
the uncle a bad guy but they made him
too likable they made him want to change
over and now he can't balance a name or
he has to pick a side especially with
the Airbender being here now the last
airbender so they have this they use all
their ingenuity they have this really
nice battle this is like a lure the ring
style battle is so creative yet these
people climbing up of the mountain to
get to this temple and you got them
throwing things down and glider is going
you have these awesome machines that
hook up their chains to the top and they
have these wheels and like tanks riding
the side of the mountain wonderful very
inventive and what happens is that uses
this new machine which is pretty much a
hot air balloon which Sokka figures out
how to control and I really like that
good science for the kids too I like how
he explains how we're gonna do it oh I
like that ingenuity because that
encourages other kids to think outside
the box use their use their ingenuity
and I always see the same thing with
Miyazaki I like it when he shows how
things work and I think that's a good
way to get kids into that and for adults
it's just great of seeing how they put
together to maybe adults can get into it
who knows not that old so what we have
is this big battle going on and they
they finally win they cast the the
people down that the Fire Nation looks
like it's all great and has this
wonderful ending where the Fire Nation
has the hot-air balloon they say we may
have lost this battle but we have gained
something really great from it
they now have a new weapon these
balloons because as always the thing the
fire nation could never get in the sky
they could never conquer flight and now
they can and that's a great dot dot dot
that's a great holy shit this is bad
kind of thing because now it's like
nothing it's going to be safe so that
was a really good I was a good area to
leave it off of the one thing I did sort
of question about this and I don't know
if it's intentional or not is that
there's one room they couldn't get into
and that's where the uncle fits the
uncle with the father I'm sorry but is
making these weapons they say only an
airbender can open it now Aang opens it
but how did they get in before um oh you
know what there might have been that
secret entrance there because there's no
one the Fire Nation guys come up that
way or something maybe that's it but
that'd be interesting if they're
building that up for something like
maybe there is another Airbender who
knows um but what I really enjoy about
this episode is that this is always a
really good debate about how close do
you hold tradition and a lot of things
that Hollywood likes to do and I'm not
entirely against it but they really like
to show tradition it's just tradition
come on
move on its yet you're getting stuck
with your traditions I need this is the
very you know screw religion side of
Hollywood that that don't act like it's
not there um but you know they're very
much you know you want to just keep
chanting stuff and live in the past and
say come on come on to move forward help
people now and stuff like that and
they're they're not necessarily wrong
I'm not saying that there's anything
wrong with moving forward leaving the
past in the past but there is something
to be said that the word there are great
Marvel's that are made it's sort of like
demolishing the pyramids to make room
for houses or something like that in
Egypt you know on the one hand yeah
you're making houses for people and
that's great but it's fucking pyramids
so I like how this is a good debate and
I like angrily struggling with this and
you can identify with it very quickly
and something like Fiddler on the Roof
you you just know we're you know who
they're gonna side with they're not
even though they try to show the
traditions they try to show how much it
means to him it's still you know they're
gonna go with the revolutionary you know
they're gonna go with the new ways they
know they're gonna go with you know the
young people essentially being right you
know even though everything doesn't
everything doesn't go their way you know
that the younger people and the people
breaking the tradition are the ones who
are more on the right eye like this is a
little bit more you're not sure I like
that they keep it questioning it a
little bit more and at the end they do
sort of say it's you know they have a
good heart they have a good spirit and
they're doing this for the right reason
so it's alright but at the same time
they are at that image of the painting
of the monks and that pipe coming
through one of the faces on the pay I
thought that was such a strong image
there's a very strong image um and and
tradition are you talking this way
because I'm using a big traditional you
know prison for tradition but it does
have a place it is important to remember
the pass it is important to look back in
the past see what we've done how far
we've come the patterns that will come
back the good of it the bad of it it's
you know films I mean if we saw movie
once and then never again if we didn't
have DVD or they didn't read release or
anything I mean we wouldn't be able to
learn as much from it we wouldn't be
able to study them and look at them our
great works of art so I really respect
the fact that they tried to get that
balance out there and they try to really
question it and don't play to both sides
but obviously you're leaning towards
this side I thought it was a real good
dilemma and it was a it was a good
struggle he was having so I did I
enjoyed this one immensely because
that's that's a tough argument even for
adults I'd be alone to having a kid show
and I thought they the way they came to
the resolution at the end what was a
good mix I thought that was a very good
resolution it's a very good way of
showing you with the crab the hermit
crab animals or whatever those were so I
enjoyed this one immensely I thought
this was a very very good one I mean it
doesn't does it tie directly into this
story I'm not much do you know that they
get a balloon
the fire nation but it doesn't matter
the filler episodes are fine if they do
them very well I thought this one's done
very well and showed us a new place and
new people and I enjoyed it immensely so
um that's ascent the soup see it the
next one